bonjour bertin mampaka merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors ce
travail de restitution s'annonce long et
fastidieux mais ça reste une bonne
nouvelle tout de même c'est tout
simplement ce que les belgo africain
l'imagination appelait jadis le
contentieux
ça fait partie de ce qu'on appelait
compense belgo congolais il n'y avait
pas que les rsg mais il y avait
également si vous permettez d'autres
d'autres d'autres biens qui faisait
l'objet d'une longue discussion dans la
séparation du combo avec avec avec la
belgique
alors c'est une bonne nouvelle car c'est
l'aboutissement d'un long processus
rappelons que le marché mme rousseau
avait demandé un avis à l'époque que
l'institution de ce bien la commune et
nations unies et que au lendemain même
de l'indépendance des velléités en tout
cas du gouvernement déjà mais pour de
vouloir faire des dons donc le procès du
loup à la bleue ceci rien avons
aujourd'hui me semble être beaucoup plus
que convenable pour régulier et les plus
rassurants dans la procédure que les
afrodescendants c'est à dire des réseaux
de s'endetter colonies belges ont
exprimé depuis plusieurs années pour que
cette transaction se fasse dans des
conditions qui soient scientifiquement
acceptable est dans un état de
conservation dont on est certain aussi
que l'utilisation ou la valorisation de
ce patrimoine soit fait de manière
efficiente
donc je pense que le gouvernement dans
lequel mon parti et le parti de la
majorité a fait une pollution qui est
convenable même si on peut toujours
continuer un crabe a estimé que que pour
certains n'y voient une opportunité pour
pouvoir comprendre les joueurs mettre
certains de ses biens sur le marché
privé avec la spéculation d'objets d'art
dont on connaît l'ampleur aujourd'hui
par seulement pour le congo mais y
compris au moyen orient gauche et à
droite on voit là un peu c'est une bonne
décision en tout cas elle se fait dans
des conditions qui sont peut-être
longues années sans mais il fallait
mettre un cadeau dit que ça c'est bien à
bertin mampaka vous vous le dit un
instant à le processus a été
particulièrement long pourquoi ça n'a
pas été fait plus tôt
[Musique]
la belgique
les rapports des nations unies et
d'autres grandes nations de 10 la
décolonisation vous savez la france à
l'algérie n'a pas été facile non plus
mais bon on était jeunes avec des combos
ça est encore un peu plus violent si je
peux dire aussi a failli de guerrero
comme une séparation qui a été par
convenablement organisé noryeva ce
support mais bon dieu donc le second
connaissance même du pillage la
confiscation de biens
le lobby puissant des coloniaux qui ont
obtenu un statut administratif pour la
plupart d'entre eux n'est ce pas on
parle toujours de nos pôles deux hommes
qui auraient commis qui a commis d'après
les historiens tels que quelques
quelques massages mais l'état le congo
belge
il était à ce moment là la
responsabilité du gouvernement de
l'époque alain commis aussi et tous ces
gens là quand ils sont revenus ils
constituaient des lobbies tellement
important c'était une grande un blessure
d'ouvrir ce dossier met sur la table
aujourd'hui je me dis qu il ya des
générations qui sont partis des
nouvelles générations
le ministre qui était aux commandes de
l'organisation de cette opération je
pense qu'ils n'étaient pas les mêmes par
sa maman était pas né quand le combo a
été courageux
indépendant donc là il ya moins d
complexe donc or on voit discuter avec
avec beaucoup plus de deux corps en
appel - des mots sur moi de partir pays
et c'est pour ça que ça a duré si
longtemps car les colons qui était un
peu comme un but reid qui considérait
que tous les biens qu'ils avaient acquis
par la ruse en france ce goût là était
légalement ça fait un nazi on compte
bien garder des liens que deux des
tableaux et des patrimoines culturels
français et six morts c'était des
transactions tout à fait honnête et
beaucoup ont eu du mal à pouvoir le
rendre je parle d'une enfant dans le
secteur privé dans ce cas là c'est à
dire
d'ailleurs c'est un problème qui se pose
tout ce qui est répertorié identifier
inventorier fera l'objet de cette
transaction
mais il existe et je dois vous le dire
là dedans de patrice lumumba lui même
n'est ce pas qui est beau nationale un
patrimoine quelqu'un dans la partie
noire mondiale pour la démocratie
aujourd'hui ça d'or a été gardée par un
policier qui était témoin de
l'assassinât
pendant des années s'ils attendent le
monde a pu être gardée
et à voir les objets est encore beaucoup
plus ces valeurs se retrouvent dans un
patrimoine privé je ne dis pas qu'il
faut faire de 2,2 et de perquisitions
dans les maisons des anciens colons mais
quand même je pense que ce qui manque
dans ce processus c'est la seul bémol
que je mets là dedans
dans ce processus le fait que aucun
n'envisage pas d'aller retrouver
certains biens qui sont d'une valeur
considérable qui reste dans le
patrimoine privé qui ont été aussi
acquis des manières son père mais je me
permet rapidement de vous de vous couper
il nous reste plus beaucoup de temps a
très rapidement avant de avant de se
quitter
je voulais savoir également si cette
nouvelle pouvait aider
les relations entre la belgique et la
république démocratique du congo
aussi vous demander vos opinions celui
qui est président que lexie s'était dit
que je trouve être un bon choix pour les
congolais lui même et d'équidés la
belgique c'est aussi son deuxième combat
parce qu'il a passé 35 ans dans ce pays
donc les relations pour moi en ce moment
elles ont elles sont elles sont
meilleures que président je pense ça va
continuer bien sûr a reconnu des
relations mais je pense la belgique
comme l'europe comme la france
n'oubliez pas que le congo et la
première est le premier pays francophone
du monde en dehors parce qu'ils pourront
l'entendre 100 millions 81 200 millions
où vous êtes 60 millions environ et les
canadiennes sont que je ne sais pas pour
une union
je pense que que ce dommage que l'europe
francophone ah oui à la francophonie des
pistards comment dirais-je développer
davantage des relations d'ordre
économique culturel un peu plus forte
avec ce pays qui reste un atout pour
pour repos pour l'europe le dire
simplement au coeur de l'afrique
les relations doit s'améliorer je crois
que le président du cellier très vite
fait face à la belgique est aujourd'hui
80 % des cadres qui l'entourent et
d'autres qui sont certainement aux
commandes de la gestion de ces musées de
vous montrer et félicitations musée qui
a été entre autres soutenu bavard par
une partie de fonds de roulements
japonais n'est ce pas eh ben ça va
améliorer des relations ça j'en suis
convaincue mais il faudrait davantage
il faudrait davantage les échanges entre
les états aujourd'hui peuvent se faire
d'une manière encore plus efficace
heures par des échanges le temps sur des
savoirs de compétences
les diasporas qui sont mal utilisés ici
tu pourrais être les utiliser dans ce
pays là si vous demandez mon opinion moi
j'ai tout un plan plus complet que celui
là ces dépenses les belges est ici qu il
entretient affaire qui coûte cher qui
pourrait être utile la barre en emploi
le suis intarissable sur son aile la
conception que moi j'ai en tout cas de
de la relation belgo congolaise
merci beaucoup bertone en paca va voir
était avec nous ce matin je rappelle que
vous êtes ses députés du mouvement
réformateur au parlement de la
fédération wallonie-bruxelles merci
beaucoup